all right here we go to La now we've got
big issues with the homeless check it
out it was completely quiet and safe and
boring in a good way
and now I'm afraid to go out without my
pepper spray they're supposed to be
housed by now and
they're supposed to put no camping signs
up I think something has to change
because people are going to just leave
California I'm wondering where that
money is even going yeah right well
democrat-led cities pouring a lot of tax
dollar money and resources and the
homeless crisis is it helping you be the
judge homeless population in La growing
10 percent over the last year swelling
from 69 000 more than 75 000 living on
the streets the mayor's trying to do
something Dave Rubin left California for
Florida and he host the Rubin report
Dave how you doing morning to you Karen
bass is the new neighbor she's got a
program called inside Stave it's her
signature initiative
um she's trying to pull people out of
tents and put them into temporary
housing how do you think it's going to
go
bill I promise you you can hold this
clip for eternity it is going to go
horribly awry every single thing that
progressives do goes horribly awry let's
not forget that it was Gavin Newsom once
a progressive mayor of San Francisco
about 15 years ago who said he had his
10-year plan to eliminate homelessness
in San Francisco San Francisco now has
40 000 homeless people most of whom are
fentanyl addicts crack addicts etc etc
everyone knows about the Urban Decay
there forty thousand is less than the
seventy thousand that you just mentioned
70 plus thousand that you just mentioned
in Los Angeles but San Francisco is a
much smaller City so everywhere that
progressives take over whether it's Los
Angeles whether it's San Francisco
whether it's Philadelphia whether it's
New York City the list goes on Seattle
Portland these things are not
coincidental that when they take over
they allow drugs on the street they tell
you you're not going to be arrested for
petty crime times things of that nature
and then the average person the average
law-abiding tax paying person they flee
and that's why I'm always very happy
when you remind the audience that I now
live in Florida we have 1 000 homeless
people in Miami I just checked before
the show and and the mayor here in Miami
Francis Suarez I spoke to him last week
and he's working on that and that's with
1 000 and these things are not
disconnected from policy and people
really need to start understanding that
well Dave you and I agree that my home
state Florida is the most excellent
state of all time and of course you
would want to live there um but let's
put up these numbers you mentioned all
these different cities that are dealing
with this LA and NYC up 10 in LA with
homelessness in the last year up 18 in
New York City how much of this is about
the criticism you get at the border that
if you have policies that are magnets
that promise people that you will make
life easier for them or help them and
some of these people desperately need
help they're going to show up to those
places
well look at New York City as the best
example of this I mean Eric Adams
basically said New York City is a
sanctuary City we're not going to arrest
you you can you know basically people
are doing drugs on every street corner I
don't have to tell you guys you're in
New York City right now and then what
happens they're homeless shelters then
get overrun with illegal immigrants and
then Adam says no no no we can't handle
it we don't want anymore so look Florida
operates in a very different way Ron
DeSantis has made it clear we are a Law
and Order state if you are illegal that
you are breaking the law by very
definition and we are not going to
tolerate it here if if California wants
to be a sanctuary State congratulations
if New York City wants to be a sanctuary
City congratulations but then again what
it does is it puts strain on the average
person the guy who's watching this right
now who's got a job who's trying to live
right and raise a family and everything
else pay their taxes Etc their money is
now going to support people who are
illegal who then are also bringing crime
and God only knows what else in terms of
culture and everything else so this is
the problem everywhere without exception
I mean someone watching this or you guys
can show me the progressive city in the
United States of America that is clean
that has a low amount of homeless people
and and a thriving economy it simply
doesn't exist she said I want angelino's
to see the tents are disappearing and
not coming back
so we will stand by for news on that
Dave ribbon will keep the interview
I will wait patiently thank you Dave
nice to see you thanks for coming on if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell